>> Tucker: THE GENIUSES IN THE
DIVISION IN THE DNC SUGGEST THEY
CAN RIDE THE RUSSIA SCANDAL TO
THE POLLS.
THEY'RE GOING AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ECONOMIC
RECORD.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS PRETTY LOW.
STOCK MARKET IS PRETTY HIGH.
INSTEAD, THE ATTACK IS ON GAS
PRICES WHICH ARE GOING UP, AND
THAT IS BAD FOR THE
MIDDLE-CLASS, SOMETHING TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT.
THE PROBLEM, OF COURSE, IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS SPENT YEARS
VOWING TO INCREASE GAS PRICES IF
ELECTED IN THE NAME OF STOPPING
GLOBAL WARMING.
2016 PLATFORM LITERALLY DEMANDED
A HIGHER TAX.
MARC STEIN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST.
HE WAS ALIVE IN 2016 PAYING
ATTENTION.
HE MAY REMEMBER THAT PLANK IN
THE PLATFORM.
WHAT'S HE MAKE OF IT NOW?
HEY, MARC!
>> HI, TUCKER.
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF A PORT IN
THE STORM.
THE BLUE WAVE IS PETERING OUT AS
IT COMES TOWARD SHORE.
YOU SAID THE RUSSIA HOAX.
I MEAN, YOU HAVE TO THINK IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW IF ALL OF THE
PEOPLE WHO TOLD US THAT TRUMP
HAD NO CHANCE TO WIN IN 2016, IF
SOMEHOW THE BLUE WAVE DOESN'T
HAPPEN AND THE REPUBLICANS WIN
THE MIDTERMS, THERE'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A SINISTER
FOREIGN POWER OUT THERE THAT
THEY COULD GET THE DEMOCRATS TO
BLAME THEM FOR STEALING THE
ELECTION SO WE CAN HAVE A
SLOVENIA INVESTIGATION OR A
TAJIKISTAN INVESTIGATION OR A
SOLOMON ISLANDS INVESTIGATION.
IF YOU'RE THE SOLOMON ISLANDS
AMBASSADOR, NOW WOULD BE A
REALLY GOOD TIME TO BOOK A LUNCH
WITH SAY MITCH MCCONNELL SO
IT'LL LOOK SUSPICIOUS ON THE
WEDNESDAY MORNING AFTER IN
NOVEMBER.
AND I DON'T WANT TO GIVE ANY
IDEAS TO THE DNC OR THE F.B.I.,
BUT IF THE F.B.I. HAS ANY SPARE
CAMBRIDGE PROFESSORS LYING
AROUND THAT IT WOULD LIKE TO,
YOU KNOW, SAY TO MINOR TRUMP
OFFICIALS, YOU KNOW, MAYBE A
STAFFER TO MITCH MCCOM, OH, YOU
KNOW -- MITCH MCCONNELL, OH, YOU
KNOW SLOVENIA HAS THE DNC
E-MAILS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT PLOT NOW THAT RUSSIA
HASN'T WORKED OUT.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE LAUGHING
ABOUT THIS THE NEXT INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL OR FOUR INDEPENDENT
COUNSELS FOR NOW WILL PULL THIS
TAPE AND USING IT AS EVIDENCE IN
YOUR TRIAL?
>> NO.
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT DID I KNOW AND WHEN DID I
KNOW IT?
BUT I MEAN, I MEAN, ONE OTHER
THING -- I MEAN, JUST TO BE
SERIOUS HERE FOR A MOMENT,
BECAUSE I DON'T REALLY TAKE THIS
THING THAT SERIOUSLY.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH A LACK OF
MESSAGE, AND TO PROFESS NOW TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT GAS PRICES
AFTER THEY'VE DERIDED THE TRUMP
TAX CUTTER'S CRUMBS AND ALL THE
REST OF IT, I MEAN ACTUALLY THE
SOLUTION IS NOT TO REPLACE THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION WITH GAS
PRICES.
THE SOLUTION IS TO FIGURE OUT
THAT TRUMP CONNECTED WITH
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO PITCHED ON THE TV AND FOUND
NEAR THE REPUBLICAN NOR DEMOCRAT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN THE LEAST BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THEM.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Tucker: I GOT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT HARVEY WEINSTEIN?
BECAUSE I CAN'T CONTROL MYSELF.
OBVIOUSLY --
DO YOU WANT TO PUT
A BOW ON THIS STORY?
WHAT SHOULD WE THINK OF THIS?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE
HILLARY CONNECTION.
THEY ACTUALLY HAD LUNCH TO
DISCUSS AFTER HER DEFEAT HARVEY
WEINSTEIN MAKING THE DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT HILLARY'S DEFEAT.
THAT'S HOW TIED IN THEY ARE.
I THINK THIS IS -- I THINK THIS
IS QUITE IMPORTANT, THOUGH,
BECAUSE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT,
THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF MORAL
PANIC TO IT THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT THIS GUY.
HE'S INCREDIBLY ACCUSED OF RAPE
BY ACTRESSES IN THE UNITED
STATES, CANADA, THE UNITED
KINGDOM, FRANCE, NEW ZEALAND,
ALL OVER THE PLANET, AND THIS
TELLS US SOMETHING ABOUT THE WAY
WEALTHY AND POWERFUL MEN USE
THINGS LIKE CONFIDENTIALITY
AGREEMENTS TO SILENCE PEOPLE AND
GET AWAY WITH THEIR CRIMES FOR
DECADES ON END.
THAT'S THE LESSON HERE.
DON'T LIVE IN SILENCE.
DON'T LIVE IN FEAR.
AND FRANKLY THINGS LIKE
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS I
THINK SHOULD HAVE A FAR MORE
CIRCUMSCRIBEED PLACE IN AMERICAN
LIFE.
>> Tucker: THERE'S ALSO -- I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT YOU
SAID, BUT THERE'S ALSO A
SUBLESSON HERE WHICH IS IF
YOU'RE WONDERING WHAT PEOPLE ARE
UP TO, LOOK AT THE BEHAVIOR THAT
THEY DENOUNCE IN PUBLIC.
IT'S PROBABLY THE VERY SAME
THING.
HARVEY WEINSTEIN WAS THIS GREAT
CHAMPION OF WOMEN AS WAS
SCHNEIDERMAN.
THE ONE THING I'M NOT IN FAVOR
OF IS HURTING WOMEN.
THEY WERE DOING THE EXACT SAME
THING.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S AN
ACCIDENT.
>> I THINK THAT'S A LIBERAL
THING, BY THE WAY.
YOU PROFESS TO CARE ABOUT PEOPLE
IN GENERAL, SO YOU CARE ABOUT
THIRD WORLD PEOPLE IN GENERAL OR
GAYS IN GENERAL OR MUSLIMS IN
GENERAL AND YOU TAKE THAT AS A
LICENSE TO TRASH AND ABUSE
AND THAT'S WHAT TIES HARVEY
WEINSTEIN, SCHNEIDERMAN AND A
LOT OF THESE MOSTLY DEMOCRAT,
MOSTLY LIBERAL FIGURES TOGETHER.
THEY SAID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS
IN PUBLIC AND THEN THEY'VE GOT
THE, YOU KNOW, THE DOOR LOCK
BUTTON UNDER THE DESK IN PRIVATE
AND THEY'VE GOT THE STANDARD
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT STACKED
IN TRIPLICATE UNDER THE DESK.
THEY LOVE HUMANITY IN GENERAL
AND ABUSE HUMANS IN PARTICULAR.
>> Tucker: IF READING AND
WRITING STILL EXISTS ONCE THIS